boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation i'm your host alan sakyan we
are now on site in manhattan in new york
city new york we are at the new york
presbyterian hospital slash while
cornell medicine
we are going to be talking about all
things neuroscience all things
consciousness all things mental health
and well-being all things future i'm
super excited to be talking to dr
heather berlin hello hello thank you for
joining us on the show so glad you're
here greatly appreciate it
and i'm really excited because heather
is super prominent in the neuroscience
field very world renowned and her
background is super long so i have a
cliff notes version of her background
she's a multi-award-winning
neuroscientist and science communicator
assistant professor of psychiatry at
icon school of medicine at mount sinai
practices clinical neuropsychology at
new york presbyterian hospital slash
wild cornell medicine and she's a host
of pbs's science goes to the movies
discovery channel superhuman showdown
star talk all stars and a big promoter
of women in steam
this is really exciting you have such a
cool background you're a huge role model
to me and so many others in the field of
neuroscience and let's do this let's
have a good co have a good chat so
um
heather this is i always like to take a
big history perspective on things to
start and i like the word that you used
you used the word sculpting
i like that word with the mind so we've
now we now find ourselves as stewards of
earth after so many billions of years of
evolution on earth and and now our mind
has evolved a lot over the last six
million years to become what it has the
nervous system's evolved much longer
than that but okay so now we're here
we're absorbing much different stimuli
than we were even a thousand or a
hundred thousand years ago
so tell us about the sort of big history
take on the evolution of the mind and
now
we sculpt forever and we sculpt until we
die so we have to be constant learning
yeah yeah well there's a number oh you
brought up a number of issues one thing
that kind of is particularly interesting
i think
you know so we've evolved these brains
in
basically over thousands of years but
really to
adapt to this sort of caveman
environment and the rate of growth of
technology
is way quicker than our biological
evolution
so we have something actually in the
mental health field
called the mismatch
theory or hypothesis of about
psychiatric illness
and basically it's that you can explain
almost every psychiatric illness
um
by basically a mismatch of the modern
environment
with a caveman brain like what we've
evolved to adapt and respond to
and so you know if you even anything
right now what we're on this 22nd floor
right well you know we've evolved to
have a fear of heights because that's
adaptive you don't want to fall off the
cliff or whatever but now you have some
people who are standing on 22nd floor
and looking out it's totally safe we
know that but these mechanisms are still
going on and so now they may have this
extreme horrible anxiety and fear of
heights even though it seems irrational
it actually would be rational if they
were in an environment that our brains
evolved to be in
so we're slow in terms of biology of
catching up to where technology is and
we are kind of like these cavemen brains
in you know modern societies and there's
going to be some mismatches
um so
you know that being said that's like
sort of the overview picture but then of
course each individual within our own
individual lifespan
is evolving over time in our own way to
the environment but you still have these
programs that are running that are you
know evolutionarily older as well that
are driving us and motivating us so
we're kind of like it's always like
there's there's a bit of a
we have this prefrontal cortex that's
sort of telling us to do these rational
things in this world that we find
ourselves in but we have these basic
basal drives that are like
evolutionarily older yeah
i like how you
make this really interesting way of of
understanding how our
the biological circuitry and systems
within ourselves has evolved at a
biological pace but technology is
exponential and the stimuli now
so
we find ourselves on the 22nd floor we
find ourselves getting the ding ding
ding ding ding like information foraging
all the time
so there's all these different we're
eating such
processed crazy
food in such abundance that's another
thing i mean that's why obesity is such
a problem because like we've evolved to
like store fat and things because we
don't know the next time we're gonna get
a meal right if you're hunting and you
know but now just everything is readily
available so these mechanisms that make
us crave like fats high fat foods and
because that was evolutionary adaptive
or sugars
it's no longer really adaptive when
everything is available in front of you
and then you start getting these
problems like obesity and other diseases
that are related to diabetes
yeah
and then you also have this real i want
to we'll we'll move into um
you have a really good way of explaining
this too there's this sort of um
there's processing that occurs in our
minds and the processing can be you know
we we normally think as oh i see things
or i touch things or i taste things and
it registers in my mind and evokes some
sort of a memory that i've associated
with that item in that collective we
we've learned that this is red and that
your glasses are red and that this food
is this taste and then there's this
unconscious sort of mind that does our
blinking and our breathing the autonomic
nervous system so yeah tell us a bit
about because sometimes it doesn't even
feel like there is free will so tell us
there's not it's just an illusion
wait what was the question what do you
want to tell you let's go let's go into
unconscious and conscious processing
um so i mean with
so so basically we've we put so much
value into consciousness because that's
how we sort of
experience the world but really much of
what's happening in the brain is
happening unconsciously outside of
awareness and not just
things like controlling your you know
automatic nervous system autonomic
nervous system your heart rate and your
gut metabolism and all the rest
but um
really
these decisions that we make our
behaviors much of it is being decided by
processes that are occurring in the
brain outside of awareness
and then we're sort of conscious this is
like the last to find out about it and
then we have this feeling like oh i made
that decision or i had that intention
but when we look at a whole slew of
neuroscientific studies
you can see that we can measure your
brain activation and see it like
moving let's say if you're going to go
to the left or the right
a number even seconds before you're
consciously aware of your intention to
go left or right let's say
so
you know
in a sense you know free will is an
illusion it's sort of happening after
the fact you feel like i have the
intention to do this but your brain is
already decided so i sometimes say like
we might have our unconscious brain has
free will we're just like the last to
know about it or something you know
because it's the brain is doing the
deciding and you're sometimes you're
conscious of it sometimes you're not
you know sometimes you get conscious
access to what your brain already
decided and sometimes your brain just
decides outside of awareness and it
never comes to consciousness but either
way the brain is doing the deciding
and you know consciousness is aside sort
of aspect to that yeah so we're
there's
there's so much uh additional
uh
aspects to uh over time that we've
evolved with this we have this gut that
means that
somehow we work with this massive gut
bacteria and tons of
neurons as well in there um we have uh
an environment that is that we think
like you said that we get to move
ourselves around and but these decisions
we are have we're mapping that these
decisions we become aware of only
seconds
after the unconscious makes up at the
mind yeah and i mean the gut is another
great example i mean there's
more neurons to serotonin neurons in
your gut than
parts of your brain and it's like well
why isn't that conscious but it is
giving information there's a you know a
lot of psychiatry is looking at the
relationship between the gut and the
brain and how that relates to
psychiatric illness and even some
experimental research in for treating
obsessive-compulsive disorders looking
at fecal matter um you know implants as
a treatment to like repopulate this
microbiome because it's actually
affecting brain function um so there's
just a lot going on or even other things
like outside of the disease realm but
like who you choose to be your mate or
who you're attracted to there's all
these unconscious things that are
at play that are attracting you from you
know smells and
behavioral signals that we're not even
consciously aware of and
uh you know they're women who you know
when you're at certain parts of your
cycle that you're going to be more
attracted to certain people than another
than others which is interesting uh so
there's just a lot going on and we think
we're so much in control when we're
really it's our biology our underlying
biology that's motivating a lot of it
what we do
yeah
and then there's this very strange
way that we this these are called uh
these these this quality of this
subjective
experience of of living
and even that
feels once you have once you have a meta
perspective on it it feels weird to feel
living
yeah well just to have subjective states
i mean that that's the thing really like
when we're talking about consciousness
you don't need language you don't need
self-awareness to have conscious we're
talking about
basic sensory sensation experience
so
first person subjective experience just
simply
feeling pain
not like oh it's me who's feeling the
pain or that feels like this or that
it's just the feeling of pain or seeing
the color red
and
with ai systems for example like
they might be able to do very
intelligent things like lots of complex
processing of like you know they can do
mathematical equations and things much
quicker better than we can
but the simplest thing of just having a
feeling or a sensation
they might not never ever do we don't
know i mean this might be a distinctly
biological trait i mean there's there's
arguments on both sides but
you know and humans aren't the only ones
other animals other species have this
have subjective states as far as we can
tell again it's always subjective it's
always first person like i don't know
your conscious i assume you are but yeah
i only know i am but
i assume other beings are
and that may also be a sort of this this
this complex uh biological processing
that's going on at the level of hundreds
of billions of neurons and glio cells
versus maybe like dozens in a fly
right and so is that a level of
consciousness that's just much much less
than ours is so there's different
arguments there it might just be a
different type of consciousness it
depends on the theory of consciousness
that you sort of adhere to
um
so if you look at the integrated
information theory of consciousness that
basically says that consciousness is a
property of the universe like gravity is
and so any time there is any kind of a
system that has a high degree of
integrated differentiated information
it's basically about information
processing
and you can calculate that
you'll get a number of five it's called
and basically that number
corresponds to the amount of
consciousness in that system
so
you could say a fly has a lower phi a
less amount of integrated differentiated
information than our brains do so they
have some sort of consciousness but it's
different than ours i mean
i like to say it's like either you have
sensation or you don't it's kind of like
an all or none and then there's
different aspects to that sensation
maybe they're enhanced the more you have
and and and julia cenony who came up
with this theory of the integrated
information theory
talks about that a bit in that that's
somewhat pan psychist right it's a yeah
it is it is somewhat that is pencil it
means that like which basically is
saying that
any system doesn't have to be a
biological system or anything that has
some degree of
integrated information can have it a
light switch has a bit of information
it's on or off so it might have some
degree of thigh consciousness but that's
sort of meaningless to me because it's
not the kind of consciousness that we're
really
talking about when we're trying to
understand consciousness light switches
aren't building
22 floor buildings and airplanes right
yeah right but you know other animals
like dolphins you know are pretty aware
and intelligent we know they have
self-awareness they can pass this mirror
recognition test like basically
recognize themselves in a mirror
and um
you know but they don't have the
appendages that we have like the
development of our thumbs was a really
important thing that we can grasp things
and hold tools and that led to a lot of
other things
dolphins
maybe could have done
the things that we do but they're
limited by their you know
appendages basically and
they do have language it appears they
speak to each other
so um you know i don't think it's
distinctly human but pansec it could
mean anything can have it to some some
degree but basically this
this theory the more um you have in your
kind of repertoire
the more like that conscious experience
is so like basically let's say your
experience of red
if the only colors you know knew of
let's say you had some sort of form of
color blindness and the only colors you
were capable of seeing let's say is red
blue and green
and according to this theory and the way
the calculations are done your
experience of red
would be very different because you're
experiencing you're experiencing red in
terms of what it's not and if your
repertoire of what it's not is only two
other things
red is going to have a different feeling
different quality to it than if you had
a million colors in your in your you
know wheelhouse yeah like the word love
in the united states versus in english
versus the word love in hindi where
there's so many different ways to
say that or to talk about what that
feels like across
similar to
you you mentioned earlier
wherever the nervous system sort of
finds itself evolving is where those
different stimuli build up such as a
dolphin in the oceans will have a
nervous system that builds up certain
talents in the in an ocean setting um a
plant another decent example is just the
it was very interesting seeing a plant
communicate to other parts of the plant
when an insect bit it
and then there was a communication of
hey like this is a stress hormone we got
stress happening right now we just got
bit right so that's kind of like
consciousness and that's some form of
you know
some form of it we might say information
information
so heather does a lot of brain behavior
relationships um
specifically the prevention and
treatment of impulsive and compulsive
psychiatric disorders um so this is
this is really crazy because this is
like seeing this is a lot seeing
patients
dealing with different ailments
providing solutions to those ailments
you even have to go to court sometimes
to say that yeah i was in court
yesterday i know
yeah
how many patients do you think you've
seen through your career oh my god
uh
i mean there's on the order of
thousands
maybe probably yeah i mean
i've been doing clinical you know i've
been working with patient populations
since
uh
that's gonna make me feel really old
right now but
two thousand probably two thousand maybe
like actually starting in like 1999 i
would say
so what's like 20 years
two decades i feel a little now see i
knew that would make me feel but
whatever yeah so two decades of a lot of
people seeing a lot i can imagine i
don't know like i'm not really good at
estimating but i imagine it's a lot of
patience and um
and plus i've worked in you know in
hospital awards where you get large
groups of patients here but but but
mostly the patient populations that i've
worked with or
done research on
are either people who have some sort of
either traumatic brain injury
in terms of the neurological patients
or
like some sort of lesion because they
had a tumor removed or
a stroke
so neurological lesion patients and
traumatic brain injury patients
and
and also patients with movement
disorders more recently who need who we
do deep brain stimulation to treat like
parkinson's and those kinds of things
and neuropsych testing of all these
patients these neurological patients and
then also psychiatric patients um and
those have mostly been people with
um anxiety disorders impulse control so
anxiety disorders mostly like
obsessive-compulsive disorder
impulse control disorders things like
pathological gambling
and
mostly people in the impulse of
compulsive spectrum and also some and
personality disorders so i did a lot of
work with people with borderline
personality disorder
and and then what i did which was sort
of novel when i was first doing this was
my
phd work was comparing people who have
specific brain lesions where we know
kind of like where the hole in the head
is to psychiatric patients under
cognitive measures to see where they
were similar and where they're different
because a psychiatric patient there's no
one place in the head you can point to
but if we see overlapping symptomology
we can know that that part of the brain
is involved i've done a lot of
neuroimaging and psychopharmalogical
studies so that the techniques i use is
mostly neuropsych testing
functional magnetic resonance imaging um
and
psychopharmalogical studies
that's the clinical
yeah and and this is a big deal because
there's i think it's um on the order of
10 million people in the united states
have ptsd
and there's just a lot of depression ocd
anxiety going on around the world
there's a lot of
in
transgenerational global trauma that has
built up over time yeah and
and we have now the tools with deep
brain stimulation all these interesting
tools are evolving um and we can
potentially
manipulate the emotions in a beneficial
way
yeah i mean well first of all i think i
read a study once where they said the
thing that causes the most human
suffering um is actually
anxiety and mood disorders and things
like depression and anxiety because some
and you would think that sounds a little
strange but other things
i don't know maybe you're talking about
like terminal cancer whatever but then
people end up dying or whatever but when
you're looking at the
living and suffering
psychiatric illness causes the most
suffering over a lifetime than any other
kinds of you know diseases that so so
the fact if we can actually and also the
other caveat psychiatry hasn't really
in the last 50 years there haven't been
really huge major breakthroughs in terms
of um
psychopharmacology
you know
we do a little tweaking of okay well
maybe this ssri serotonin reuptake
inhibitor selective serotonin reuptake
inhibitor is going to
you know affect this serotonin receptor
we'll do a little tweak and it's going
to do this serotonin receptor or that
but we haven't really cured the diseases
but with more more recently things like
deep brain stimulation
um it's very promising it's been used
for many years with uh with movement
disorders
and a lot of work being done here
cornell's deep brain stimulation for
like parkinson's and other kinds of
movement disorders and now we're moving
into the realm of psychiatric illness
where we can go in and stimulate parts
of like certain sort of circuits in the
brain to help with depression and ocd
there's also as alternative treatments
um
things like
ketamine has become really a big thing
right now with treating people
especially for treating suicidality
and um and depression major depression
and other things like psychedelics in
the use as like with a therapist yeah
psychedelic psychotherapy we just had
rick goblin on the show again we love
maps yeah we're huge fans maps is cool
abs is cool so there's all of that you
know and mdma for ptsd and
psilocybin for you know anxiety
addiction yeah yeah
so i think you know we are moving
towards helping these people but it's
still
we're it's a path it's a long path
yeah and you're showing very promising
results um with helping with um ocd and
with depression you're over 50 on on on
helping
remove people from having those sort of
tendencies significant growth away from
those tendencies
you mean with the dbs or yeah i think so
yeah with well basically yeah these are
like
um
treatment refractory patients so they're
refactoring patients and they're
treatment resistant
so these are patients who are very
severe and they had to have tried
a number of different drug trials and
um other like things like ect electric
shock therapy and really nothing has
worked and then what they used to do is
go in and lesion parts of the brain for
these p and and sometimes it would work
but if it didn't you have a lesion in
your brain so
that's not great but
you know when you're desperate that was
the alternative and now
with these debris deep brain
stimulation it's adjustable it's
reversible
and you can control it remotely you can
turn it up turn down if it doesn't work
you haven't really lesioned your brain
um but you're seeing pretty
nice results i mean it's not everybody
who gets it but you know if you can get
even 50 improvement in in maybe 70 of
patients that's like a big deal yeah
and then there's this is also important
to say correct correct me if i'm wrong
but there can be these
people because behavior can be changed
by
by tumor growing in their prefrontal
cortex or pressing on their amygdala and
these are the times when they can
potentially turn from a great citizen to
someone that becomes a pedophile or
someone that kills their family and this
is uh
then then then you do see the in the
neural imaging then you see have to go
and testify and say that
this is what happened you can also go
and remove the tumor and then they come
back to normal to their normal self yeah
it's like these these where we're going
from correlation to causation so
basically
you know you are your brain so when
things happen
if you have a tumor if you get a brain
lesion if you have a stroke
it depending on where it is it can
affect your personality you know what
makes you you it's really just a
construct of your brain and if your
brain changes it can change
fundamentally in many ways who you are
your personality and those are classic
cases especially with the prefrontal
cortex lesions that you see with like
the case of phineas gage back in the
1800s and this big metal tamping already
went through his prefrontal cortex
completely changed his personality um
and then there's more modern day cases
like this person who developed
pedophilia in his 40s and was going to
be imprisoned and then they signed a
huge tumor in his prefrontal cortex take
out the tumor symptoms go away a year
later the
symptoms come back and the tumor had
grown back and so
it really starts you to get questioned
about well how much control do we really
have and
you know everybody has subtle
differences in their brain but does that
is that an excuse for bad behavior
um but i i like it too i think in the
legal system it's
does the person have the capacity to
have self-control and if they do we hold
them responsible for their actions so
but if they have a huge tumor or if they
have under activation of certain parts
of the brain we say they don't have the
capacity to be responsible
and you know then we have different like
consequences for them yeah
and you've you've been a big proponent
of having have creating a greater sense
of compassion and uh empathy towards
other people's
ways that they've their minds have been
sculpted in through their environments
and that
sort of uh of of
of essence and camaraderie across the
planet can can really be those that that
that
crucial next step for us to really find
that sense of unity amongst each other
is to is to care more about how we got
how did you get to that point where you
feel that way now
yeah i mean you know
because i look at i mean everybody i
look at people as people but also you
have to remember you can't get
angry at someone if you're like okay
that person
is
whatever you take your bit like they're
so annoying they're so neurotic or they
always get really upset at the littlest
thing or whatever you know that might
just be
their genetic underpinning that's the
way their brain developed that's who
they are you can't
you know you can't get mad at someone
for their predilections you can ask them
to understand what their predilections
are and to try to you know modulate them
but
people are wired in different ways and
they have different you know different
size amygdalas and different
connections and
you can't expect everyone to be the way
you want them to behave you have to take
into consideration and even people at
extreme ends who are pathological you
know
i mean you can a very good example is
with the president of the united states
right now i mean he does things that
people really are just
you know like how can somebody do that
or or you know people who are so
sociopaths and domino empathy
um
i i feel bad for them because
they have sort of that's abnormal they
have a disorder it's a brain disorder
and
you have to kind of
have empathy for them
and say i i understand that that's what
that person is they can't help it
so
if we could have more compassion
for other people
and not expect them that they should
behave in this way or that way but just
understand that they're
it's their biology yes we can have some
control over it when our own running
around you know doing whatever we want
and but
to the extent that they have the
capacity to have control over those
things you know and some people just
don't
and we we
that also that compassion and empathy
can drive us to a more nuanced discourse
amongst each other on how to best move
forward
because there's a lot and this is a good
segue there's a lot to to deal with as
we move into the
world of neural prosthetics as we move
into the world of these augmentations
there's a there's a lot um that that we
have now the power to manipulate emotion
um to increase intelligence to augment
metabolism there's a lot of things that
we're going to be playing around with
genetic engineering with this
also neural prosthetic additions now
what do you
what what what are you what i guess
there's just there's so much there's so
much to do here the conversation around
the ethics and the geopolitics of things
the conversation across the wealth and
the quality of things you know where how
do what are your what's your synthesis
on this
so i think that the technology is going
to continue to develop because
let's say things like neural implants um
because it's helping treat disorders
right everybody wants that like
you see these parkinson's patients and
you know they're they're able to
function or psychiatric disorders um and
that those are the neural uh deep brain
stimulation but there's also brain
computer interfaces where you implant
these microelectrodes and
basically
you can use your thoughts to control a
prosthetic limb and now more recent
studies are showing that like a caltech
you can get sensory information back to
the brain and stimulate it so these
prosthetic limbs not only can you
control them with your thoughts but they
will send that you can feel them and so
they really are becoming like your real
limb
or people who are in uh who are
completely paralyzed who can now
communicate using these uh brain
computer interfaces so these are great
things and they will continue to develop
but will happen
is inevitably
that people start using them in a
healthy brain to enhance it and sort of
for cognitive enhancement and then
then you get into these ethical
questions of like who can afford the
implants is it i mean because obviously
if somebody has one they're gonna have a
huge advantage should say if you can
increase your memory capacity
over the people who don't so maybe
nobody's allowed to have them or and the
same thing with um genetic modification
i mean right now it's not legal we can't
we i mean
technically we we could make designer
babies but legally we're not allowed to
because
or we're not even allowed to sort of
experiment in that in that way
mutations that are causing severe
diseases those are ones that should be
eradicated right but so it's it's this
it's a really
hard because there's positive and
there's and there's negatives and what
do you do and so i mean we thought the
same thing with stem cell research and
then
it was allowed and it was at the time a
very big deal of i remember
george bush like wasn't going to allow
stem cell research and then now we're
finding to do all these amazing things
to help
cure disease so
the thing with the genetic mutation is
that
you might change something for one thing
but then you don't know what the
consequences are going to be for other
things you know it's not
excuse me
it's not as straightforward as
in in some case some cases it is you can
just it's a single point you know
mutation you take that but for other
things it's more
like we find the genetic relationship
between autism and whatever but then you
might take something out that could have
coded for some other thing we don't know
about that's right yeah so
that's very complicated and that's
harder but
if you're just talking about brain
computer interfaces
it's inevitable that someone is going to
pay for
their implant to help them do something
you know to become superhuman and then
what do we what do we do then so
these are academic debates we're having
now but they in our lifetime there will
be real
questions that we have to answer in real
time yeah yeah
there's a lot of potential with with
malevolence and it's and we gotta we
gotta work ourselves through we gotta we
have to work ourselves through
transcending malevolence and
transcending ego and finding the unity
and love between each other before
it seems at some times we're rushing to
the transhumanist era and that's and
that rushes
can be harmful because we don't we don't
have the capacity for oops moments
anymore the you know the seat belt in
the air bay killed tens of thousands
maybe 100 000 people but existential
risks are not okay for the civilization
so yeah yeah well you know we'll
probably kill ourselves with climate
change or something before then who
knows he's so optimistic
i'm from the east coast so we are a
little realistic yeah yeah we're a
little bit more like
no but
i like that i like the i could i could
switch into an optimistic world view um
let's say if i was to do that
[Laughter]
yes jaded east coast new yorkers um no
but i mean
i i think that it's
i i'm sorry i have to be pessimistic
again i think that i couldn't it's the
last it lasted for like a second
yeah i thought
well it's just that i guess i'm a
realist maybe that's it i'm more like i
feel that way too yeah and i think that
you know
humans are not that
evolved we like to think we're so
evolved okay but we're really not that
evolved and
some humans are more evolved than others
that's right but as a species if you
take the average and i can tell you this
and this is going to sound terrible but
like
you know
even if you're talking about like
intelligence or whatever you know which
is not everything i mean there's so many
other things but
if you do i do a lot of like
intelligence testing for various reasons
and the average is a hundred yeah an iq
on iq yeah
and if you see what a hundred looks like
yeah you know i mean we're not that evil
you know we're just trying to get by
most people are trying to get by yeah so
this idea of like we're going to
transcend everything and be above it all
i'm not that optimistic but also it's
not just because of that but i just
think that
we we are still like animalistic we have
these basic drives we have you know
freud talked about a lot of that as well
you know we have a kind of
sort of death impulse as well as a kind
of
like life impulse in a way or that kind
um what did you call it like
some cathexis or whatever he had like
you know but the positive kind of
what is this it was your libido you have
like a kind of positive energy but then
there's a negative and
when it comes down to it like you can
really test how far humans evolved when
there's scarcity
yeah yeah that's right because then
we're
fighting right away yeah yeah yeah like
if you take the most evolved people and
then put them in like uh
the titanic and see who's going to go
that's right you're going to get now
within the population you're going to
get a couple who are really noble and
like you know what i'm going to die for
whatever and
women and children first first yeah and
you'll get some of those people in the
but that's not going to be the majority
you know and then you're gonna have a
lot of people who are just looking to
themselves and survive
so i just i don't know how
i guess that's why i'm saying i'm not
that optimistic that we are going to
like
evolve past all these kind of basal
basic
drives
but there are there are good people
there are good people everybody is good
and bad okay everybody but there are
people who are more selfless who are
more giving yeah and maybe they'll over
time if those people have more children
yeah there'll be more people like that
you know i mean one of um my husband's
shows about evolution he said the key to
everything is just don't
it's women have control of who we choose
to mate with yeah yeah and his whole
thing was just
don't sleep with mean people
so we if women
just only choose
altruistic or
good people to procreate with over time
that's how we can change the course of
human evolution in our in our species
yeah um
who do the mean guys procreate with them
there's a lot of questions that that
arise you actually had this good um
you had a bell curve up for a moment
with uh at the center of the
distribution being a hundred on the on
iq and then um half of people being
below that half people being above that
towards like 140 and towards 60.
and
those are the types of moments where i
do have a deeper sense of realism that
if that is
in iq is just of course like we said
there's one way but at the same time if
you take a potential like a hierarchy
and you um and instead of sorting the
hierarchy based on socioeconomic status
based on wealth maybe you sort it based
on altruism and uh and ones that have
transcended their ego maybe the ones
that are furthest along in their
spiritual journeys on earth
because if that was the case then if we
put more of them into positions of
deciding on some of the resource flows
and the frameworks for increasing the
baselines across the world we just move
so fast we're not slowing down and
thinking we're living in this the basal
limbic
systems of thinking and not the slow
down prefrontal executive functions
plan things
help
have the empathy in that altruism but
it's so hard when you have to run around
and and just to feed yourself and pay
your rent and stuff so we you know we
have a
it's a really it's a slow down and think
and it's a and it's a stop fighting
against each other so much
but i agree i mean just with the thing
like iq is not the thing but like you
know because you could have
an average low iq that's and be
a hugely like evolved
spiritual however you want to say it
um person
and i think that
like you're saying one of the keys is
the people who are
in power unfortunately aren't those
types of people who seek out these power
positions right because they're not
about ego
and so that's right you know we'd have
to rearrange society in such a way that
we at least have
someone like that
on teams of where people are making
decisions um
because that's the only way like things
are going to change on a more global
scale like you need the decision makers
to have either themselves have some
empathy or compassion or have people
around them that have that
um
one thing to have faith in is the
decentralization of power and the
distributed computing systems that are
going to enable us to
democratize data and democratize
resource flows in better ways and and
i think i think that
that can that might that may be able to
help quite a bit
uh heather okay this is this is this is
an important field for us to for us to
talk about
i've now i i think i've i think i've
identified it and you uh you correct me
if i'm wrong i feel like a big part of
being a creative person
is to go to
the edge of your own capacity and also
aim to get to the edge of kind of what
the collective knows and try and make
things around that edge of knowledge
tell us about yeah the neural basis of
creativity and um yeah that's something
that i've been really interested in
so
i think
i mean creativity it's very hard to
quantify now all the way back when i was
an undergraduate my senior visas i
wanted to
i wanted to do a study on creativity i
wanted to look at the effect of
music
on creativity
and
and different types of music and how
that affects but i got stuck because
there was no way to quantify creativity
at that time and there are some tests
about divergent thinking so like
you know how many different ways can you
use this paper clip or not
but
there wasn't it wasn't really satisfying
like what i was thinking i mean that's
thinking outside the box that's
diversion thinking it's sort of part of
creativity but
there was nothing so i ended up looking
at the effects of music on productivity
because that was easier to measure and i
was only i wanted to graduate so i
didn't want to be there forever so we
had to modify a bit but but basically um
i think
creativity is
you it's knowing all the basic facts you
take in all the knowledge you do your
homework you know you consciously take
in all the information and then
when you can make these novel
associations between ideas or put the
information together in a new way that
nobody thought of before
that's sort of sometimes you call it
genius or
but it really is to do with creativity
as well and so
um if you use people like as examples
like darwin or something you know people
say he's a genius but
what he did was he took
information that was readily available
to everybody
and put it together in a way
that you know was creative and nobody
else had thought of that or there were
some people sort of tangentially
thinking about lamarck and stuff but
you know and and and that's how i see
creativity and what what it is is that
the unconscious is an unlimited capacity
consciousness is limited so it can only
do hold a number of variables and minds
and do calculations on them but if you
if you take in all the information
consciously you relegate it to the
unconscious it can do much more and
that's when people say they have like a
flash of insight or suddenly comes up
from the unconscious
um you have to like kind of let your
unconscious work on it and then and i
think also when people are in these
being creative in the moment like
spontaneous creativity or improvisation
there we find that there's a certain um
brain state or a neural signature that
they get into in this kind of flow state
and where you get decreased dorsolateral
prefrontal cortex activation
um which is kind of like the filter
system in the brain it filters your
behavior to conform to social norms it's
about your ego as well so people your
ego is turned down people say it's like
flowing through them or coming from
somewhere else because you don't have
that sense of self
um
and then you have increased medial
prefrontal cortex activation which is
like the internal generation of ideas so
it's coming from within
filter system is turned down so it
allows for novel associations between
ideas love it and you know and then
people are it's associated with very
positive emotions people want to get to
that state because
also
parts of your prefrontal cortex that
ruminate and like are anxious and think
about the future consequences of things
it's kind of like turned down for a bit
when you're in these states you're in
the moment and that is really like i
think it could be very therapeutic for
people because you're shutting down the
inner critic the inner voice that's
always like what are people thinking
what about this what if something
happens or
and just you're in the moment
creating or maybe just doing some
activity like that you're really focused
in like rock climbing or you know it
could be a physical activity as well
um
but that's that's like the sweet spot
right that you want to get to and we're
we're starting to understand the real
underpinnings of that
state yeah yeah
the flow seems to be one of the most um
meaningful experiences that we can have
in life
and
yeah it's super creative and it and it
drives us towards hopefully towards our
goals that you know we're in flow going
towards towards things that we find most
fulfilling in our lives i would say i
would say um
it's a state where we feel most
i think
it's meaningful but also where you're at
most sort of
almost at peace or at ease or you're in
you're you're most productive or some
but you're
feeling you're doing what you're
supposed to be doing in that moment in a
way
but i think another source of meaning is
um
connection with people and so like a
float state
or being these spontaneous creative
states can be all about you
um but there are also other meaningful
things when you're connecting with other
people or even if you're
performing with an audience and there's
a feedback loop between you but i think
that
also is very meaningful and powerful
yeah i'm happy that you also picked on
the multi-disciplinary
understanding of of of reality when you
do go deeper into different fields and
make connections across those fields it
can give you
really cool insights into how things
work
um
there's been a lot of talk about
neuroplasticity
we want to get as far away from nerd
generation as possible we want to retain
our cognitive capacities as long as
possible at the peak cognitive capacity
so tell us about what your thoughts are
around that space
a patient i was just talking about
earlier i was running away because i was
going over a patient was
neurodegenerative disease and i was
going through all the different there's
many many different types of
neurodegenerative diseases and it's very
hard to
quantify you know who has what but it's
you know the patient's like well what
can i do and
you're just like well there's nothing we
can do it's just this is what's
happening and it and it's where you feel
really frustrated as a
you know
as as a neuroscientist or if you're
treating someone as a doctor you're like
but there's nowhere to go from here and
so that that that but but but the brain
is
malleable you know over the lifetime so
if you're getting away from the idea of
let's say you don't have
neurodegenerative diseases but just the
normal
aging brain
we can have
we can have what we call cognitive
reserve which is like a protective
factor against those things so
if in your life
you um
are active mentally you keep your brain
active you you know you read you
are constantly using it like a muscle
you're going to develop more connections
and pathways that might be redundant in
that you might be able to lose one but
still have kind of a backup and
that's what we mean when we say
cognitive reserve so you can change your
brain and as you are living and develop
it so that it will be protective more
productive
if
these certain neurodegenerative diseases
kick in or just the normal effects of
aging
but we haven't figured out how to kick
the actual
diseases yet
yeah
so it's almost as though the more that
we stay in the states of flow and the
more that we stay in curious states and
creative states that the potentially the
hopefully the longer we can offset
neurodegeneration more active we stay
or the effects of the neurodegeneration
the effects of it will take longer to
kick in
yeah
heather have you um been looking into
the um
the neural importance of meditation
um so it's not research i've done on my
own um but i i have looked at some of
the work and um
what's interesting is that some of the
similar patterns you see in creative
flow states you also see during types of
certain types of meditation
also in
in in certain types of hypnosis
daydreaming in rem sleep
there are similar kinds of patterns of
activation when you're in these states
but they're usually
associated with
novel associations between you know free
floating thoughts there doesn't have to
be any structure or order to them
and that whatever happens you're kind of
turning down executive control
prefrontal cortex function and
they're usually associated with very
positive
feelings
it seems that meditation may be one of
those keys towards unity on earth
i do really think so well i think any
time you are in a state where you
can get your ego to dissolve temporarily
i have patients who
don't have a sense of self at all and
that's not good either
so our egos are important in some
ways and that's why we've evolved to
have them
um there are people who have no sense of
self and it's they dissociate and
they're not really connected to
themselves and that
so i think the idea of meditation and
getting to these states where you lose
your the ego dissolved is good as long
as you can control it
if you can't get back in
that could also be anything sort of
taken to the extreme is can be
problematic but
the more we can do that and and that's
when people get this feeling of oneness
with the universe and with everything i
think it does
it can change how we interact with each
other
so it's good to be in those states and
have those insights and feel what it
feels like to be sort of egoless so that
when you go back to your everyday life
you can maybe have more compassion for
other people
yep there's no hate there there's only
love there right yeah that's nice that's
it's so
damn important
um okay heather you've been you've now
been
doing
science communication across hosting
shows across doing your your all your
work is translational also directly
impacting patients um you know this is
you go and speak in so many different
places now
science communication is so crucial it's
like the ones that are at the edge of
knowledge in their different scientific
fields
need
sometimes need help getting the word out
in more fun relatable entertaining
creative ways that can inspire new
people to to work themselves up in that
in that scientific
awareness so tell us about that
my impetus towards scientific
communication and um
yeah i mean it really
for me it's an
it kind of evolved and this was natural
process so i
i was doing just being an academic and
and going to conferences and giving
talks like academic conferences and i
realized i really like enjoyed
giving talks and i was getting very
positive feedback from it
which was nice and i also had always as
actually all the way from the time i was
in elementary school all the way up
through college i did theater i was a
theater and fine arts minor in college
so i acted in play as always
yeah and so i really i really like enjoy
being in front of audiences and like
connecting and that energy because not
everybody likes to
public you know do public speaking but i
really enjoy it and i like i can feel
kind of an energy of an audience and
you know i can see like if something's
not working how to like bring them back
in and um
so but i was just doing my thing and
then i i did some
it was actually like a debate
i was doing at um the uh intelligence
squared no no this was long before that
this was like i was doing a debate at
the uh new york psychoanalytic institute
okay it was like a serious like it was
like a serious debate with all these
academics but it was filmed it was put
online and then like somebody from
discovery channel saw it and called me
like do you want to come i get this call
like in my office
we would fly to london like next week
and audition for this show and i'm just
like what you know
it's awesome
that's how you do it that's how you do
it you just got a call one day you're
like okay and what it turned out was um
this is just sort of like my origin
story or whatever but
unless like sort of what started getting
me into this path because like i wasn't
sort of seeking it out and it just
but i was doing like public talks for
the public
a bit anyway so if they find me out
there and it turned out they had been
auditioning for like months for these
hosts and they were and everything were
like whittling it down and they were
down to their like last like 10 and i
just got like flown in in the last
minute like oh and so i didn't have a
lot of pressure on me because like these
people were like really like and i was
like oh whatever free trip to london
i'll go so i was really relaxed and had
fun and the audition all these like
discovery execs were there and there it
was like really serious and i was just
like whatever
and um and then they like offered to me
like okay so you're gonna be on the road
in like a few weeks and you're gonna fly
around the world and do this and that
and it was just like trial by fire i had
to learn and before like within a few
weeks i literally was flying around the
world meeting people with extraordinary
abilities trying to explain how they
could do what they can do via science
and experiments and film crew following
me around and like it was just like
you know i learned as i went
and it was a great experience um
which i just i i loved and i enjoyed and
then i said you know like actually i
think i can do like i i it's it
it is actually a skill that you have to
develop and people think it just comes
naturally you really have to learn
especially if you're a hardcore like a
scientist how do i talk about these
things that are complex in a way that
people who are not experts in the field
are going to like connect with it and
engage with it and um so it's a learning
curve but
you know then it's kind of a snowball
effect and once you start doing it then
people ask you to do this or that and
and over time you you
yeah you know i don't know i don't know
how it all happened but i really enjoy
it i love
getting people excited about science
um and
but i always will have to have my like i
can never
just do that like i always need one foot
in like doing the the work the science
um
and then i but but if i did all just
that and no it would be like a bit too
serious for me i need also the like
communication part to like have fun and
get people excited whatever but if i did
all that
i would feel like it would maybe be a
little too superficial for me like i
need both i need the it's like ying and
yang
um for me personally but i love it i
want to get young girls i want to get
involved and
when i was growing up there was no for
me female role model
scientists
you know i remember seeing the film
contact with jodie foster and i was like
oh my god like we could be you know and
that was really cool for me but there
wasn't a lot of role models so i think
things are getting better
and i think there's obviously now is
huge movement in that direction
and you know i just i do what i do i try
to mentor young girls like who are
coming up and
get them excited about science and it
can be cool and you don't have to you
know you can have fun and it's not like
you're all nerdy or whatever the
stereotype
was or is so
i'm really passionate about it and i
really get excited
to get other people excited about about
science and the brain
yeah it's as though we have both adults
that are scientists that don't
know that even
speaking about what they're doing to the
public even exists as an option so
having them be introduced to it as an
option and then testing themselves out
in it that's that's great and then with
like you were pointing out with young
girls as well it's like we did again
just is it an option you have to see it
to be it right you have to have that
mentorship
to get it done
yeah become that yeah and i've been
fortunate to have people in the sort of
field of science communication kind of
be mentors for me
um like neil degrasse tyson and and bill
nye you know i was fortunate enough that
they kind of
were mentoring me along the way and um
you know i learned a lot from them so i
think it's all about yeah you have to
see that it's possible and then say like
why couldn't i do that too you know
yeah
okay i want to power around on a couple
questions okay these are questions that
we typically ask on the show on the way
out what is a core driving principle of
your life whoa oh you mean just like
basic simple questions simple questions
i thought it's like you know like pizza
or
girls
whoa okay wait just like out on a simple
note so what is the basic a core driving
principle of your life
a core driving principle of my life oh
my god um we're just keeping it light
here
okay
wow you didn't give me any time to think
about this either
um
improv i know improv um well
god core
for me there's a couple of things i
guess i mean this is really off the top
of my head but what drives me is
the pursuit of knowledge i want to
understand
why we're here how things work i just i
want to understand you know that just is
a driving factor to me however you want
to
however that manifests it's just the
strive to to know to understand how
things work why we're here
where do we go you know how does the
brain work
um
and
another thing that drives me
is
to be present like be to because this
life i'm so always aware and maybe hyper
aware of how
short it is and how lucky we are to be
here and what does this all mean
but like don't forget to just be and
enjoy it and appreciate and the people
around you um
their time with them is so precious
whatever it may be like with your
children or your parents or your
grandparents or your friends
those those moments are so precious so i
want to be there and i would sacrifice
like
you know for me it's not about success
in a career
that drives me like i don't care about
that much i care about the pursuit of
knowledge and that's kind of what drives
me but it's not about
awards or accolades it's really i would
give up things like that to spend time
with
people i care about because that's to me
so important in life
um so i guess that's sort of like a
driving force and motivator in terms of
just how i organize and structure my
life
you know i'll give up some things that
might seem prestigious because like
spending time with my kids is
invaluable
um
yeah i think i think those are pretty
are pretty good and you know it's so
typical like silicon valley like leave
the world a better place
like i do try to like help i think i
want to have an impact by helping people
yeah and it's not even about
making a big scientific discovery but
it's really for me where i get the most
gratification personally is helping
individual people
like live a better life and that's where
i feel like i can have an impact because
whatever you know if i'm gone like you
know people probably won't remember me
but that doesn't matter it's about the
impact that i make on individuals while
i'm here that makes a difference yeah
yeah so yeah it's a couple of driving
forces sorry those are great
those are great
those were really important heather
thank you okay if you could
rebuild
civilization from scratch wow so now i'm
god okay how would you design it
oh my god what are these questions
if i can rebuild civilization from
scratch how would i design it
wow okay
from scratch
i don't know i can't go that far back
but let's just say um
i'd like it to end up being i don't know
how we're going to get there
but
where um
i i kind of like the idea of like
there's no money
you know like
we're all equal it's i guess it's kind
of like socialist but like everybody has
their basic needs met
you know it's maybe it's like a barter
system or something
right and this one like civilization
like how we kind of live you know i
think that we should
it's totally possible if we could start
over again from scratch and forget where
we got to now but it's totally possible
with the resources we have on this earth
to everybody live
at a comfortable
level and you know it's that that that
is possible oh yeah and you know i don't
know how we could get there from where
we are now but if we could start from
scratch
i would love that money is not a thing
it doesn't matter everybody gets
equal
all like good quality of life
that would be ideal for me you know for
i think that people don't have to worry
struggle think about how they're going
to pay the bills everybody gets health
care
you know there's not the super rich
and there's not the super poor it's just
homogeneous and then we can actually
like maybe spend time enjoying our lives
or we people have the time to actually
enjoy the time that they're given here
and not have to spend it all just trying
to survive and get their basic needs met
yeah yeah so a re a redesign um where
the the baseline of of basic necessities
that are needed to survive are are quite
high that are filled and then from there
wherever people want to creatively
endeavor they may yeah so pursue in that
way we're not like you said just trying
to survive but rather enjoying the time
here yeah yeah freeing up people's time
so they can
be creative they can write a book they
can paint they can do the thing that
they want to do in this life yes yes
um okay um
we this wouldn't be simulation if we
didn't ask you
is this a simulation
oh is this a simulation
um
i'm going to say the probability it's
possible
the probability is low from what i
understand of our basic physics however
our experience of all of this
is a simulation of the in the brain
so you know i'm not going to say the
physical things here are a simulation
but i think our perception of reality is
a simulation we're all running
simulations sort of or i don't know if
that's what you mean by simulation but
yeah i mean yeah definitely and we're
creating this reality in our mind which
doesn't necessarily correlate to the
real reality but i do think there is
like a real physical world out there
we're just limited in our capacity to
experience it because we're just
experiencing it via these like little
three pound pieces of matter i mean
they're pretty complex and interesting
but
we're limited and we might be limited in
ever knowing you know what it all means
or
because we're sitting here with these
tiny little cavemen brains trying to
figure it out
but um so yeah we're kind of running a
simulation in our own head
but
i do think that this is really out there
okay okay
the the the code is uh being tapped into
so that we can better understand if it
is actually right simulation or not
code is math in so many ways oh yeah no
math is the language of the universe
yeah i love math is like i love math
it's everything well there you go
language of the universe simulation
pretty much yeah
heather what's the most beautiful thing
in the world
for me
yeah my children
why
i'm like gonna cry now i can't believe
that that's all it takes for me
um
i can't explain they're just
when i look in their eyes and
it's just their life
it's life it's everything that's it
they're the most beautiful thing in the
world to me that's that's the only like
if god forbid like if my time comes
whatever like all i want to do is like
if i can one last thing to look at would
be to look in their eyes yeah yeah wow
that's it
i mean like you know the typical
response would be like a sunset or
something but no it's just like we've
had a lot of replies really good replies
to that question and that was a good one
we also you you have this you have
photos of you you know you speak this
like a true mother that's cradling their
their child right past post-birth
um that
i've i've aimed to get behind my own
mother's eyes as she's teaching me about
the story of holding me and
and
that is so profound yeah yeah it's just
it's just everything it's who we are
it's humans it's like
to me there's just nothing more like
beautiful than that
um
yeah that i can think of
yeah and that's and that's that's the
last question and i
would i would normally be ending the
show right now but because we have so
much creativity improv freestyle flow i
want to see do you want to do you want
to do a freestyle improv me me and you
both we're going to freestyle improv
yeah okay like what what like um we're
gonna let's do a beat with some sort of
a flow maybe
yeah yeah we can switch we can switch
back i can't beat box i can't be okay
well how about i start with the beatbox
and then and then you can just do
something i'm gonna do like a freestyle
rap yeah yeah and we'll make it around
like you know science that's what i
always try and do i try and make it
around something thought provoking
you're aware that it's my husband who's
the right i know i know papa
but hey you guys did you guys did that
uh off broadway we did the show off the
top but he freestyled not me so i'm just
like this is i am not like i'm looking
at the camera for this one i am not a
freestyle rapper i'm not a rapper we'll
get baba i do nothing of rap it's all my
husband but i'll you know i'll play
along let's do it okay so i'll give you
a beat to start are you a freestyle do
you do your friends no i i dabble for
fun because i try and again this is the
whole thing is the more that you process
this the more uh practices the it kind
of feels good and and what not okay
we're gonna do it all right let's do it
okay here we go you're gonna beat you're
into the beat okay
okay
here we are at coal or now it's
tomorrow's gonna snow and i'm trying
really hard just to get into the flow
we're talking about science and i don't
know what else to say i'm gonna switch
it over to him okay
awesome here we go heather so right she
has been in some good flow talking about
neuroscience let's go it's been great
talking about psychom heather is so
brilliant it's been such an honor
talking to her talking to you amy to
inspire you here we go we're gonna build
the future you and me and her and us all
together let's go
yeah so stuff like that yeah yeah i like
that i like that i like that should i do
a closing i can do it okay let's do it
okay okay okay ready okay okay
we're almost at the end i'm gonna say
goodbye there's nothing more beautiful
than my daughter hannah skye i don't
know how to rap but that's okay i'm
living in the moment don't know what
else to say that's it it's not a
simulation yet but who knows what
happens when the we evolve the internet
[Music]
i love it thank you for joining us for
that little yes thank you so much
thank you heather yeah thank you
thank you and there's so much to learn
about what's actually going on in our
minds and in our worlds and heather is
has been such a pleasure to have on the
show thank you again we greatly
appreciate it
thanks everyone for tuning in huge thank
you we'd love to hear from you in the
comments below let us know your thoughts
let's get some chat going on about some
of the topics we discuss on the show
also go and check out the links below to
how there's work and we would love for
you to build the future go and manifest
your dreams into the world everyone and
join us so we can continue supporting
this project doing cool things like
coming out uh to great places to
interview amazing leaders so thanks
everyone build the future much love and
we'll see you soon peace